good evening and welcome to Tucker
Carlson tonight I hope you had a great
Thanksgiving a day away from politics
and mass media with people you love and
who love you back
it's really a spiritual Spot Treatment
that's the ideal we ought to do it more
than a couple times a year but we are
back and now that we are an obvious
obvious observation all prosperity in
this country depends ultimately on
energy our consumer economy runs on it
it takes energy to make things and bring
them to your house our Tech economy runs
on energy too A lot of it how do you
think they keep their server Farms
running energy is pretty much in fact
the key to everything that Americans do
for a living it's the key to health care
and Agriculture and yes media and travel
and construction entertainment
even Finance which is symbiotic with the
real economy depends in the end on
energy because you can't lend money to
businesses if they no longer exist and
if Energy prices go up high enough they
don't exist
so given how Central very obviously
Central Energy is to everything that
matters in America it's hard to believe
that the body Administration would
intentionally make energy much more
expensive because we know for a fact
having seen it repeatedly through
history that high energy prices will
crush our economy faster even than the
covid lockdowns did people will become
poor some of them will die that's not a
guess it will happen so given all that
it's unimaginable that anyone but our
enemies would want to raise our Energy
prices to the point where our economy
collapses and yet that is exactly what
the bid Administration has decided to do
and to do it they're using twin
instruments of climate policy and their
war against Russia
the effect in a nation with the largest
recoverable oil reserves on planet Earth
many Americans can no longer afford
fossil fuels
and once again this is not an accident
it's not a natural cycle we're going
through politicians and policy makers
are doing it to us on purpose
now the midterm elections are over the
media can finally begin to cover the
inevitable results of these policies CNN
for example just ran an article about
Americans who are worried about freezing
to death over the winter in America
one 63 year old woman in Philadelphia
called Charmaine Johnson said that she
is torn between heating her home and
buying food and of course she's choosing
food because she has no choice it's
miserable she said it's like living in
an igloo
another man a 67 year old man called Tim
wisely said he turns on his heat only
when his teeth begin to chatter
you can't go food shopping and get oil
it's one or the other he said it's a
horrible feeling it's a feeling I
wouldn't wish on anyone
and it's a feeling that Americans have
not had in Generations these are
American citizens living in a major
American city that used to be considered
first world and they can't afford heat
and it's happening not just in
Philadelphia but everywhere
average home heating prices went up 17
last year and they're up another 18 this
year again not organic this is the
result of policies from the Biden
Administration and its allies
not just in the Congress but in think
tanks across Washington and in the
entire American news media this did not
happen by accident as Fox Business has
reported once winter arrived the problem
is going to get much worse we're riding
around with oil for less and they say
that their customers are struggling to
keep up with these skyrocketing costs
across the board heating costs are
expected to be high this winter heating
oil in particular up 68 year over year
today they filled up this tank with
about 950 worth of home heating oil a
year ago the same amount of oil would
have cost them closer to six hundred
dollars that's why the company tells me
that some customers are just doing
without people have gone without hot
water and heat for for a week just
because they haven't had the money to
call me and say hey come on in
they don't have the money for hot water
or heat again what country is this any
country that can't provide hot water or
heat in the winter isn't much of a
country and again it doesn't need to be
this way because we have the largest
recoverable oil reserves on the planet
what happens when energy costs continue
to rise while people run out of money
and it doesn't take long according to
data from the Bureau of economic
analysis households are spending their
cash reserves far faster than anyone all
those economists projected even as
credit card debt reaches historic levels
if you're borrowing money for household
expenses on your credit card at
exorbitant rates
you're done as Business Insider reported
quote Americans have already burned
through a third of their pent-up savings
that's nearly three times more than
previously thought and signals spending
will soon slow down yeah that's what
happens when people run out of money
they stop spending it because they don't
have it and then the consumer economy
slows
so when energy costs rise again just to
be clear because it's not sophisticated
economics here when they rise so does
the price of everything else and the
first staple to rise in cost is the one
that you have to have and that's food
watch
on the menu this year for Thanksgiving
Rising prices overall prices are up 7.7
percent from last year and grocery
prices are more than 12 percent higher
than a year ago here's what it means for
the family grocery bill as you shop for
the big day first the turkey per pound
prices for turkey are up 17
year-over-year an average frozen turkey
costs roughly 2.38 cents a pound that's
up from 1.74. now you can blame the
avian flu outbreaks and higher fuel feed
and labor costs because of inflation
running near 40-year highs what about
eggs eggs cost 43 percent more than a
year ago butter and margarine are up 34
percent flour is up nearly 25 percent
your pies are going to cost more to make
these higher prices could potentially
change Thanksgiving plans so why is this
happening well you heard the reporter
allude to it but not really explain it
there are of course many factors but
there are two big factors that are
driving this driving inflation and the
rising cost of everything around you and
they are in order global warming policy
and the war in Ukraine
now as it always does the left use
people's best instincts compassion and
care for the planet to subvert them into
supporting these two lunatic policies if
you care about people you support the
war in Ukraine if you care about the
planet you support global warming policy
but of course neither one of these was
about what they said it was about both
of them were designed to Spike energy
costs to increase the control of the
people currently in charge and to enrich
their donors
so if you wanted to fix this the very
first thing you would do if you wanted
to help the American middle class would
be to force a ceasefire in Ukraine that
would help the world and it would help
our middle class then you would
encourage more domestic energy
production because we have the domestic
energy
then you would take a look at the
trillions we have spent on renewable
energy solar panels electric cars
wind power this is made a small group of
people incredibly rich but it has put
our grid in Peril and it has raised the
cost of energy beyond the reach of
middle class Americans but the byte
Administration is not looking for
Solutions just the opposite they're
looking for ways to squeeze a few more
dollars out of an increasingly
impoverished American middle class
according to Bloomberg this week and
we're quoting the IRS says more Auditors
and upgraded technology could help raise
as much as one trillion dollars
oh so you have less money and they plan
to take more if that's not an act of
hostility what is it is an act of
hostility they don't like you and
they're not hiding it
but big picture every other major
company in America is laying people off
but the IRS somehow thanks to Joe
manchin the moderate from West Virginia
the IRS somehow has the dough to hire 87
000 new employees and they're coming for
you they didn't hire those people by
accident they hired them to take more of
your money
so businesses who have to forecast for a
living have seen this coming and they're
preparing to cut workers
and so what this looks like if you take
three steps back is an economic death
spiral ahead of Christmas shopping
season when Amazon usually adds
employees Amazon is now laying off
employees a lot of them ten thousand
people laid off from Amazon and the
founder of Amazon Jeff Bezos is actually
encouraging people his customers not to
buy his products watch this
the economy does not look great right
now things are slowing down you're
seeing layoffs in many many sectors of
the economy people are are slowing down
the probability to say if we're not in a
recession right now we're likely to be
in one very soon if you're individual
and you're thinking about buying a new
you know large screen TV maybe slow that
down keep that cash see what happens
same thing with a refrigerator or a new
car or whatever this takes some risk off
the table if you're a small business
maybe delay some Capital purchases do
you really need that new piece of
equipment maybe it could weigh a little
bit have some cash on hand just a little
bit of risk reduction could make the
difference for that small business if we
do get into even more serious economic
problems so you got to play the
probabilities a little bit wait so the
guy who sells big screen TVs on the
Internet is telling his customers the
source of his personal wealth not to buy
big screen TVs off the internet really
that's how worried he is
the actually for maybe the first time
ever is caring about you that's quite
amazing and he's not the only one Bezos
is not the only one who's worried that
something bad is about to happen to our
economy the global economy in October
the IMF warned that 2023 will bring a
recession for most of the world that
same month the CEO of JP Morgan the
country's biggest bank Jamie Diamond
said a recession is almost certain in
the coming months
so what do you do to avert a disaster
well you probably can't stop it you
should know what its outlines will look
at take a look at the housing market if
you want to know home sales are at their
lowest level in a decade as the FED
raises interest rates to fight inflation
mortgages become too expensive
but if the FED were to cut interest
rates home prices would go up along with
inflation
you see the problem here we've reached
the end of monetary policies ability
to tweak our economy
so faced with all of this the one thing
you'd hope is to have an Administration
that understands what the problem is it
might at least be interested in fixing
it and taking care of the middle class
people who don't have a margin people
who are on the bottom they're always the
subject of Arkansas what do we do about
the homeless
what do you want people to make 80 000
in the New York suburbs nobody cares
about them
here's Joe Biden explaining the straight
face that actually everything's fine his
economic plan is working
folks my economic plan is showing
results people are starting to feel it
we're making progress on bringing down
inflation without losing jobs folks are
seeing much needed breaking inflation at
the grocery store as we head into
holidays
so that's pathetic and everyone knows
it's pathetic and maybe the only upside
of the body Administration is that
there's really no lying at this point
this isn't working
they just did better than expected in
the midterms the Democratic party
unfortunately but we're now facing the
next election in 2024 and no sane person
wants Joe Biden to run because everybody
gets that this is unsustainable even the
media gets that at this point so the
question is who replaces Joe Biden and
what can that person do about the
disaster that his administration has
created subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube channel to catch our nightly
opens stories that are changing the
world and changing your life from Tucker
Carlson tonight